what's up everybody it's your boy Zack
Evans I'm here at BuzzFeed and I'm gonna
make my co-workers rap battle yo Chris
have you ever freestyle rap battle
before yes do you want to write back I
do not want to rabbit
alright Quinta Chris Round one let's do
this so here's a couple rules I'm gonna
lay down for you guys you get ten points
just for like low- two points for every
time you cuss you get +2 if you mention
a trending topic Duke Zayn Malik
eyebrows cats and dogs in taxes so if
you mentioned one of those that's plus
two points for you you guys got it I'm
about to kill my competition like Duke
Wisconsin you'd be missing Quinta you'd
be missing the family be lookin like
where's Quinta I don't know she's five
feet under you cook him I got the heater
on my lap I bleep it out what was that
bring it back my man looking at me like
ham Chris rent I'm gonna tell you
something yes I'm black and I can read
my eyebrows on fleek like Zayn Malik
your hair is nappy in trashy just like
this beat do your taxes are you rapping
are you shining your feet get some new
shoes what you're trying to defeat you
got your camera out you need to tape
this put it away
I like this bacon quickie you just want
to write batter what are you gonna do
next I'm gonna go to the kitchen and get
a cup of noodles you ready
isn't that ready oh yeah I'm ready your
arms look weak have you even been
lifting what's your next video week 2k15
yo I'm hot like Duke
I'm fresher than an airplane on that
chook that's what I'm saying
Kris you can't fight me I'm an Ivy
League gangster and I'm ready to fight
you um I'm hopping in here right on the
same beat I'm a wrap for you so let's
call this a tree my mom says I need to
smile more
I said mom Duke winning final four yeah
look I'll get an erection looking right
here on my own reflection
Nik then you should leave right now I
call that [ __ ] a one direction that's a
Zayn Malik reference you see it eyebrows
that's the next thing I'll be flicking
my eyebrows on fleek don't really know
what that phrase means now for the main
battle yo wassup Daisha
are you interested in freestyle rap
battling someone no pick your opponent
has AI been done so I'm challenging you
to rap battle MC giggles let's do this
my name is deja but I don't know Hussein
is Zayn Malik but my average hour on
fleek I don't know what stop this beat
talk about Zayn Malik you think your
eyebrows are on fleek did you hear about
Duke your face makes me want to puke how
do you feel pretty accomplished comment
who you think's the greatest emcee at
BuzzFeed you already know when I walk up
in the door they be saying right he's
like oh he just got that stupid flow
when I step right on the flow it's like
you gotta go cuz he know where Jack
Evans and I'm about to do the show
that's right
here we go now here we go now cats and
dogs
you were frog